hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Anthony
DeLeo
uh-huh and we're gonna watch the trailer
for the Penguins of Madagascar car we're
excited for this I speak for all of us
right now granted we have not discussed
it yet but I can tell each one of us is
excited in this room right now you see
Madagascar Khloe you miss one and two
must have been very hard to keep up with
the storyline
yeah have you heard of the Penguins of
Madagascar
do you like the Penguins the Penguins
are the best part about those movies the
lion yeah this is my niece this is my
brother and who better to bring on for
the Penguins of Madagascar then your own
family because this is a family fuelled
film when the world needs saving it will
take the most elite team on earth
skipper
Rico and private were the elitist of the
elite haha
the creators of Madagascar okay boys
this is it the mission we've been
preparing for our entire lives remain
calm
penguins you are now under the
protection of the north wind grab it
Dibble me we're not going anywhere with
you
the north wind is an elite undercover in
defeating an elite undercover
interspecies toss yeah force dedicated
to her helped dedicate it up again it
was a cop help themselves
mmm
skipper we've got to be five miles up
that pretty much limits our options I
make my own options
brilliant move skipper but they always
seem to be outside to play
I've kind of got caught up in the moment
well hindsight's 20/20 oh why don't you
what she's in the same bird strike
Lordan DreamWorks Penguins of Madagascar
now we're talking let's get to work 400
meters 300 meters fake American Kowalski
sorry sir
218 yards ok then it's clear what we
need to do next right you've never heard
the song highway to the danger zone yeah
you don't know why they using that song
though because it's good yes I was about
to say if you didn't know that I was
gonna be very upset
I just bought Top Gun good amazon.com
well looks funny it looks adorable looks
obnoxious it looks like it they want to
make some money they're going to yes
congratulations three bricks you wanna
watch that movie Chloe she said yes the
riddling I gave her is not working in
our favor to get her to concentrate it
is actually creating the exact opposite
effect you know you seem like the right
person s what do you think about what's
going on to the Republicans and
Democrats right now Chloe Benghazi all
right I think that this is not going to
be a good film I think on Rotten
Tomatoes it'll give it about 25 percent
but I'm gonna be forced to watch it
anyway because of the person behind me
you gotta hear attack she has a
wonderful sense of humor
the littlest thing she finds hilarious
all right guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe subscribe you
can subscribe to Chloe and Anthony's
channel Jabby koi tail wasn't that bad
huh I'm shouting sorry the more you
watch a video that many returns for you
but stinking was not bad this is shock
of 2014 all right third video saying
this Internet still down but I give
shoutouts can't access the shout out
list right now that that's online for me
I'm gonna give some shout outs right
here I have a shout out for Troy Murphy
ray Murphy is a awesome awesome person
who introduced after Steve Jobs I want
to give a shout out to my friend Arzu
she never watches his channel she's a
good friend of mine and she knows I'm
she's never gonna but Arzu that's an
interesting version
Arzu our zoom our Z like that Lion King
character and third shout-out I'd love
to give to a guy who's been commenting a
lot lately named NBA Lakers nation
that's his name a lot of those actually
to youtube name on his birth certificate
it says it's actually pronounced na
Lakers nation that B is silent
[Laughter]
[Music]
can you speak up my Sunday but for you
to lead us in prayer
no I'm gonna keep this pardon right for
the ending